we're thankful to be here brother here's
john wall watched by kobe white to start
the night
and that is what made john wall
spectacular at times for washington
because that's what i'm getting a sense
of with some of the free agent signings
some trades some coaching changes feels
like mid-range has a chance to get back
into the game well
it should because if you've got guys who
can there's a three-point shooter by
demarcus cousin it's a good defense by
zach levine made it tough on eric gordon
and a steal by cousins he'll take it in
he's got five
i mean his drive driving kick and they
need guys to make shots
marking and rips away the offensive
rebound cousins deter the attempt at the
rim
and the rockets come back with it when
you hear them talk they've always wanted
to play with each other just never could
be able to get into that situation
here is boogie taking it to the rim how
about that finish by boogie cousins
wow you see right there turnover that
pass was not there
you can't make that pass if it's not
there go to your next option and wall
with the pull-up
here is gordon he will likely end up on
the bench for the rockets this year
coming off the bench with hardin and
wall playing together
there is john wall exploding to the rim
[Music]
on his hip and pretty much goes where he
wants to go there's another turnover and
white was looking for carter
nwaba all the way to the other end
tipped in what a play
good effort by john wall when he's on
the floor
defensively the bulls are really good
you can't tell tonight but
consistently his first two seasons the
rookie getting the start here in the
second half
he's watching danielle house to start
wall sets up cousins that's a three
yeah you got to get out to him you can't
let him get a foot in the paint or he's
going to get to the rim and score he did
a good job of getting out there
there's there's another three that's
three threes out of the gate basketball
cappella wasn't a three-point shooter
but this guy right here can knock down
three-point shots
you see the injury issues that we
discussed
wall throwing it back out for cousins
wall will take it over white and sink a
three